ma che storia di merda
che storia di merda
due anni della mia vita
ma che storia di merda  (piange)
che sfigato, che sfigato
c'è io mi sto facendo problemi
perché non so se lasciare una persona
ragazze..Ruben è più rassegnato di me
Ruben è più rassegnato di me
va bene, va bene così, va bene
e l'ha portata a cena, e l'abbracciava all'idromassaggio
e poi per finire in bellezza
chiudi le tende, va bene
va bene così. Ma no, mi fa ridere, mi fa ridere
ma quale rabbia, mi fa ridere, è uno sfigato
credimi, non ho parole per offenderlo
è uno sfigato
sfido qualunque ragazza
di vent'anni a stare con uno così, la sfido
adesso vado a vivere da sola
esco con le mie amiche
mi sono laureata, mi trovo un lavoro top, penso al mio futuro top
e conoscerò l'uomo della mia vita TOP
è due anni che va avanti questa situazione
e lui lo sa
l'ha sempre saputo
è due anni che va avanti questa storia
non entri qui a fare la vittimina del cazzo
e poi te ne vai pure nella stanza con la tentatrice. Bastardo
io la figura della polla che sta con il pollo
che un giorno si sveglia e non vuole più fare il pollo, non la faccio
no
ciao
come stai?
bene e tu?
abbastanza bene. Come hai passato questo periodo?
bene, ho riflettuto tanto su me stesso
e da questo percorso ne esco fortissimo
allora Ruben, io vorrei ripercorrere con te
quella che è stata la nostra storia
io mi sono messa con te perchè mi
davi sicurezza
eri il mio rifugio
sono entrata nel villaggio esausta
all'inizio non mi sei mancato
dopo neanche
nonostante il fatto che io non ti ami più
oltre ad essermi strusciata con tutti
i tentatori e averti sputtanato non ti ho mai
mancato di rispetto
francesca, sai qual è la differenza tra me e te?
che tu non mi conosci, non mi hai mai conosciuto
tu pensi che io l'abbia fatto?
non mi conosci, era uno scherzo Francesca
devi credermi Ruba, tu le qualità che tu hai
le ho sempre riconosciute, ne sono orgogliosa
io l'ho detto a tutte le ragazze che sei un pollo
che sei uno sfigato, che non sai pagarti le bollette
io l'ho sempre riconosciuto. Io dentro di me
quando tu ieri hai detto che sei stato il ragazzo più bravo del villaggio
io dentro di me godevo
godevo perchè ho detto cazzo mi sono comportata come una merda
e lui è stato il ragazzo più bravo del villaggio
ti reputi così top
così astuta, come hai fatto a stare con un pollo come me?
io ero innamorato di te, adesso non lo sono più
perchè Ruben è un ragazzo speciale
non vorrei che ci lasci...
non riesco a...
no guarda veramente
questa notte sono stata malissimo
e sono arrivata alla conclusione che preferisco
fare la figura della polla
che sta con il pollo
piuttosto che fare la figura della polla e basta
Ruba mangio Sottilissime dalla mattina alla sera
voglio tornare ad essere
la polla che sta con il pollo di pelle d'Apollo
ma che cazzo sto dicendo (ride)